la primera vez en 19 años que un
presidente francés viaja a lituania para
una visita bilateral sin embargo no es
lituania si no ve la luz el centro de
las discusiones en una reunión con la
líder de la oposición bielorrusa
exiliada svetlana tica nos calla macrón
dijo que francia seguirá ofreciendo su
apoyo al movimiento prodemocracia y nos
prometió hacer todo lo posible por
ayudar en las negociaciones durante esta
crisis política en nuestro país
dijo que el tiempo es crucial porque
mucha gente está sufriendo por esto
mucha gente está en la cárcel y él hará
todo lo posible para liberar a todos los
presos políticos
pero es un delicado acto de equilibrio
para el presidente francés queriendo
ayudar a belarús mientras intenta no
provocar la ira de moscú en oposición de
sus hijos sin rulo con nuestra manera de
verlo es que si queremos construir una
paz sostenible en el continente europeo
tenemos que trabajar con rusia porque
compartimos una historia
geografía no podemos actuar como si
europa fuera una isla lejana a rusia
el líder ruso vladimir putin ha dicho
que belarús se enfrenta a una presión
externa sin precedentes y por el momento
francia está actuando sola la unión
europea aunque condena la violencia no
ha impuesto sanciones macrón ha pedido
que la organización para la seguridad y
la cooperación en europa se haga cargo
de la mediación en el conflicto